I used to want to stamp the world
closer you get the more you see the
great darkness within what is your
mission to stop the war but for the war
to end all wars
cannot stand by while innocent lives are
lost
be careful Diana
whoo she's my secretary sir she's a very
good secretary
because our sacred duty to defend the
world and it's what I'm going to do
II
I used to want to save the world
this beautiful
but the closer you get the more you see
the great darkness within
I learned this the hard way
a long long time ago
what is your mission to stop the war
what for the war to end all wars
weapons far deadlier than you can ever
imagine
what can be Howard
wherever you are you are in more danger
than you think cannot stand by while
innocent lives are not
be careful
who is this woman she's my secretary sir
oh she's a very good secretary
it is our sacred duty to defend the
world and it's what I'm going to do
ah
[Music]
how can a woman possibly fight in this
place we use our principles although I
am NOT opposed to engaging in a bitter
fisticuffs should the occasion arise
you